We’re told from a very young age that lying
is a bad thing.
But in Hollywood, dishonesty has a habit of
getting rewarded.
Some of the world’s most popular actors
might not be where they are today if they
told the truth early on.
These are 9 Famous Actors Who Lied To Land
Roles, Part 2.
Sandra Bullock
Sandra Bullock is one of the most prolific
actresses in American history.
And since getting the career boost she needed
back in 1992, she’s appeared in around fifty
movies since.
The actress has admitted to lying about her
age to the team behind Love Potion No. 9.
But she didn’t go the traditional route
of making herself younger.
Sensing that the casting directors were looking
for someone more mature, Bullock actually
added three years to her age.
Magically transforming herself from a 26 year-old
into a 29 year-old.
Wow, she really IS a good actress.
Whoopi Goldberg
Not unlike our friend Sandra Bullock, Whoopi
Goldberg also had one heck of a time getting
cast because she was too young.
But where Bullock exaggerated by only three
years, Whoopi tacked on six.
Why not?
Go big or go home, right?
We can understand why she was so determined
to be successful in showbiz; because it sure
beats working in a funeral parlor.
IMDB cites Goldberg as having over 150 acting
credits to her name.
If we’ve learned anything from this, it’s
that lying works.
And the comedienne has been working steadily
ever since.
Jessica Chastain
Jessica Chastain came out of nowhere.
And suddenly she’s in every movie.
But we’re not complaining.
The talented actress caught the attention
of audiences in the Terrence Malick vehicle
Tree of Life.
Also in 2011, Chastain appeared opposite Emma
Stone and Viola Davis in The Help.
And at one point she was even slated to appear
in Iron Man 3.
Because the actress’ success seemed to materialize
overnight, there was very little information
about her.
And because Hollywood has a grotesque fascination
with the age of actresses, some people were
upset that they couldn't immediately figure
out how old she was.
George Lazenby
Quick!
Who’s your favorite James Bond?
Did you say George Lazenby?
Probably not!
It seems he wasn’t really anyone’s favorite
on-set either.
1969’s On Her Majesty’s Secret Service
was the debut and the finale of Lazenby’s
turn as 007.
You may be wondering how he even got the job
in the first place.
By weaving a web of lies in his audition.
Marketing oneself if obviously a huge part
of any job interview, but the actor took it
to the extreme.
And made himself sound a lot more desirable
than he actually turned out to be.
The director eventually found out Lazenby
had exaggerated his success, and the actor
was not asked to reprise the role.
Carla Gugino
Audiences will probably recognize Carla Gugino
as the voice of the ship in Batman v Superman.
Just kidding!
Even though she actually was the voice of
a ship, the actress has played substantial
parts in films like Watchmen and Sucker Punch.
But if Gugino hadn’t lied about her age
back when she was sixteen, we might not be
talking about her right now.
When auditioning for 1989’s Troop Beverly
Hills, the actress fudged her birthday and
said she was a couple of years younger.
And, as directors have a habit of doing, the
director found out after she’d already been
hired.
He admitted that if he’d known she was lying
at the time, she wouldn’t have gotten the
job.
Ouch.
Morgan Freeman
Ladies and gentlemen we present to you the
man, the myth, the legend: Mr. Morgan Freeman.
That’s right.
The golden voice of Hollywood might have told
a teeny little fib when negotiating his role
in 2013’s Oblivion.
Allegedly, Freeman was only supposed to be
attached to the movie in a narrative capacity.
But apparently he wanted more than that, and
it’s rumored that the actor lied about having
throat trouble in an effort to get more screen
time.
Lie or no lie, if Morgan Freeman says he wants
a bigger part in your movie because he thinks
it’s awesome, you give him one.
Case closed.
Quvenzhané Wallis
Parents only want what’s best for their
kids.
And some will bend the rules farther than
others to make sure that happens.
So when Quvenzhané Wallis and her parents
saw the casting call for Beasts of the Southern
Wild, they all agreed to keep the same secret.
Being only five years old at the time, everyone
pretended she was six.
Wallis won the casting agents over, and guaranteed
herself a spot in the movie.
In the four years since, the actress has begun
cultivating an impressive resume.
Wallis was in the critically-acclaimed 12
Years a Slave, and played the titular character
in the 2014 film adaptation of Annie.
Chris Hemsworth
Audiences have become so accustomed to seeing
Chris Hemsworth dressed as Thor that it’s
easy to imagine he’s actually that imposing
for real.
Apparently this is something the actor is
all too aware of, since he’s admitted to
lying about his height.
In an effort to be more desirable to casting
agents, Hemsworth would shave approximately
two inches off his height.
For whatever reason, those two inches seemed
to be the keys to the actor’s success.
He’s been going hard since 2009.
And thanks to the ever-expanding Marvel Cinematic
Universe, there’s no telling when his reign
as Thor might end.
Eddie Redmayne
Eddie Redmayne has been getting a lot of press
over the past few years.
The actor blew everyone away with his portrayal
of Stephen Hawking in 2014’s The Theory
of Everything.
And Harry Potter fans are looking forward
to his debut as Newt Scamander in the upcoming
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them.
But back in 2005, he was the horse-riding
Earl of Southampton in the TV miniseries Elizabeth
I.
The only issue is that he couldn't actually
ride horses.
Redmayne misinformed the bigwigs during the
audition process, and when it came time to
do it, that’s when the actor chose to come
clean.
What do you think of our list?
Know of any other actors who lied to get roles?
Tell us about them in the comments, and subscribe
to our YouTube channel for more videos.
Thanks for watching.